Good morning,
We're going fishing today
and we're going fishing for tuna.
Long fin tuna.
Hopefully we'll get a yellow
fin as well but we'll see.
We're going to pick up Dad Ross
and then we'll be on our way.
We're going to Cape Town.
Alright, early morning.
Oh thank you so much.
We stopped for some much needed coffee.
It's still pretty dark out.
Coffee?
Yes please. Take one.
And we are here.
A little bit misty, a little bit cloudy.
Alright guys, so we're going
to go with Hooked on Africa.
That's Sean and his crew.
And we're going to see if we can get some tunas.
This is it.
Good morning.
How are you?
Good good.
Here we are.
Nikita you ready for this?
I'm ready for the big ones.
Dad Ross, you ready?
I'm ready.
Look at these rods.
So we've been driving for about an hour
and the water temperature is a lot higher
as you can see there.
Just about 17°.
Alright, so this is quite special because we
got a big trawler here and he's bringing in
the nets and what that creates is a lot of
birds as you can see in the sky who are just
feeding on some of this stuff here.
And then hopefully some tuna.
See the hike coming up?
Oh yeah chum.
There goes some of the chum now.
We want to attract the fish
feeding on dead fish there.
Quite exciting Nikita?
Yeah it is.
Here we go.
Alright we gave it a try
here ... didn't get anything.
We're just going to troll the area
to see if we can get any of them.
Sorry, oh no problem, so fish on!
Keep the pressure.
It's happening guys.
We are on here with a fish.
Ross is on with a tuna.
Hold it, keep reeling.... reel reel reel reel reel
Keep the line tight tight tight.
Still there.
Yes, yay.
Just keep the line tight.
Small winds, small winds and halfway.
Follow the swell.
Halfway.
At the same time we're trying to get more fish.
Yeah.
OK.
Fish swimming around here.
Yes, coming to bite we'll hook more.
That's how it works.
That's the theory.
OK.
If we were fishing a competition
I wouldn't be allowed to touch.
This is all the way from the US.
I mean you can reel.
If I could figure this out I'm starting to get
it I think. Yeah, yes yes get it get it oh man.
Ah so I think we got a big one.
We're taking our time.
We don't want to lose it
but keeping the line tight.
He's behind the engine now.
That's another one.
That's it, reel reel reel.
Okay and again okay that's what you going to get
So the tactic is you don't use your own power
to reel in these fish, you use the swell to
your advantage.
It's big.
Is it big?
You've been playing it for almost 10 minutes now.
Heavy.
Just like a bass.
Just like those big bass you catch in the US of A.
Go.
There we go.
We're winning we're winning we're
winning we're winning we' re winning.
This is an African fish.
It's not American fish.
Yes done ... well done.
Are you getting tired?
No, he's fine, that's good.
Little by little
He was going - he's getting closer.
Slowly but surely.
OK, half of one.
That's him.
Ross your first big tuna!
Yeah and then maybe we need to
bring it to the front.
Ready.
That was a tough fish this one.
Got to move him.
yes there you go
Very nice.
When you're dressed
by a 60 year old man.
Yeah, that's funny.
Yeah only inch by inch done.
Any go.
Well done, well done, well done.
Not bad for your second time in this the ocean.
See the bird?
Oh yeah.
So you see what they're doing.
While Ross is fighting this fish,
they're also throwing chum in so preparing it
here that side as well so they're trying to
get some more tuna while we fight this one.
You see they got a problem with these birds
because whenever they throw the chum in and
even the hooks the birds come and take it.
Yeah it's all good.
Yeah.
It's quite heavy.
Heavy.
He's a big boy, oh yeah.
He's going to be so worth it.
That's a yellow, see it on the water.
Look how pretty it is.
That one.
Atlantic yellow gray head yellow.
Nice.
Hey.
If you tell your birders back home you saw
Atlantic Yellows they'd also be impressed.
He's been over 15 minutes now.
He has some fight left.
And again.
Go Ross, go, got him, he's coming,
he's coming, he's giving up.
No experience like this?
No.
So when a yellow fin tuna comes
closer to the boat they go in circles and then all
you can do is just take them in little by little.
Walking the dog. Walking the dog.
Let's go.
Reel reel reel.
You don't need
to go to the gym you can just do this.
You can sleep on Sunday on the airplane.
There we go.
Lot of sleeping.
40 hour flight.
You can sleep then.
More passion, more passion,
more energy, more energy.
There you go there you go there you go.
South African fishy.
Welcome to South Africa.
On the reel please.
We got to go let's go Ross.
Let's go let's go.
Just lying here on the top and you can
see here, the fish is getting close.
Seeing some color again.
You gotta stop reeling.
Nice fish.
Reel.
Ross, it's reel and again, again.
What side you want me?
Wow, yes.
That is a massive tuna.
That is huge.
So I wrestled a steer before but this is amazing.
Keep watching keep watching keep watching.
Look there here he comes.
They can't get him in.
Too big.
What do you think?
Welcome to Africa!
Yes, holy cow!
There we go.
High five.
Lotta fish.
That's a lot of fish.
Okay Nikita, the bar was set pretty high there.
Yeah you did.
You have to go higher.
You're up.
How's your arms?
Feeling it.
Wait for tomorrow.
You've been fighting that one for over 20 minutes.
That's insane.
But what's really important to us is
that we show some respect to this fish.
Really beautiful fish.
I'm going to wash it down.
Take some pictures.
Put it on ice.
Just look after it.
Some guys catch it leave it on the
deck and.... it such a beautiful fish.
So we showed respect.
He put a good fight.
Right.
Nikita, come!
Let's go let's go we're
just taking photos and then that one went!
So that's how quick things going to happen.
Where's your back thing?
And Nikita is on!
How's it feeling Nikita?
Nice.
I want you to square up okay?
Want to come back here?
So just come with me here.
Come back this way.
OK perfect.
The fish will come around.
We'll bring it back here.
All good.
How's it the feeling?
That's perfect.
Inch by inch. Small ones.
Ladies always angling.
So that is number two on the line.
OK Nikita.
There's a seal now.
It's starting to pull.
It's not so big huh?
Not that big.
But what are you saying?
It doesn't feel that big.
But now it is starting to pull, huh.
Come on Nikita... come on.
This is a big one.
And chasing the birds away.
You guys aren't even scared of the birds, huh.
What's wrong Nikita?
He's fighting a bit now.
Big one.
This fish wasn't that big but not its big now.
It's fighting.
Come on Nikita.
Big one. Whoooo Nikita.
OK, it's getting really hard
Coming up on 10 minutes Nikita.
Come on Nikita. Come. Well done, well done.
That's it.
Think of your brother.
Big brother, this one's for you.
Relax, relax.
Lekker, Nikita. Lekker!
I'm totally hooked on Africa.
Do you think it's going
to be bigger than yours Ross?
I think it's going to be bigger than mine.
She's got the skill.
You know, what Ross caught doesn't really matter.
This fish, compared to those
Bassy catches back home.
Second trip to the ocean.
Yeah, and a big fish like he
caught yesterday, that's special.
And he thought that was special.
Bring him in, bring him in Nikita.
Come on Nikita.
This is is a good spot, right here.
Almost here.
Mine ain't going nowhere.
Take your time Nikita.
Not too much time.
Hallelujah
When I tell you to stop winding
you just move to the back.
See color?
Yeah seeing the color.
It's looking beautiful.
Oh it's a nice fish.
What we do now is we notch the skull -
expose the spine - okay - to kill the fish
as quickly as possible.
OK, here we go.
And we take this.
Stay with this, your rod.
We're going to go down the spine.
Standby.
That was fast.
Quick, easy, well done.
Thank you.
Well done Nikita.
It's OK good!
Nice!
Well done Nikita!
Awesome.
That's your biggest fish.
It's my biggest fish.
OK we need to get another one.
High five Nikita.
Yes.
Well done, well done.
Good, you got a big one.
Got a big one.
Well done both of you.
Got a nice one.
Yeah fist bump.
That's awesome.
Now, we only need to see if I can get one.
Yeah, you're going to get the Grandpa's.
Fish on Daniel, woo hoo.
Fish on!
OK, there's a smaller one.
It's a long fin.
Long fin tuna ... smaller than the
other one but still really nice fish.
So you guys can see we're right behind
the trawler and when it's processing
all the fish it comes out here on the side.
And then you might get a tuna or two as well.
So that's the idea.
See the door ... the doorway?
Everything's coming out.
Yeah, morning, you copy Captain?
Yeah, I just wanted to find out from you what
time will you be pulling your net again over?
Alright okay thanks very much for that.
We got a couple of nice fish behind you
when you pulled it last time so I was just
wondering if you're still going to be in the area.
Thanks very much for coming in appreciate it.
OK.
Thanks very much.
It's 2:00 o'clock.
Perfect.
Now this is interesting.
So the boat just started
pulling in the nets so that means the birds are
going to increase and also maybe a few tuna.
Let's see what we can get.
That's what we're hoping for yeah.
Nikita's sleeping.
Ah!
The net top is on the bottom and these two black
things on the doors that hold the net apart.
OK, so now it's a feeding frenzy.
The birds and also seals and underneath
fish that you can't see.
There's more tuna.
They'll take the lures.
Come on.
Dad Ross go, they've got two on.
Woo and it's starting to rain.
Woo at the same time.
There we go.
That's good.
Thank you.
High five
High five.
Beautiful fish.
Two more Nikita.
Two more.
How was that?
That was awesome.
Quick burst of excitement, yes.
Now they're cleaning the deck and we're
moving forward oh there we go another one.
This time is Nikita.
Oh, lost it.
Sorry Nikita.
The crew is working really
hard to get us some fish.
It's quite nice here actually.
You can go to the toilet if you go down
there there's a nice toilet where we can sit down
for ladies and then there's some snacks over here.
There we go.
Nikita is on and it's raining.
My hand is slipping from the rain.
Do your best.
You get it?
It's coming in right here.
Watch the rod, what's the rod
Jarrod.
There we go, in the rain.
This is fishing.
So there were these birds called Sterretjies
we call them, right, and they saw them flying
around here and then we went just to see
what they're looking at, and there you go,
we got some long fins.
There we go.
This one feels nice.
Woo oh man this is so much fun.
This one is bigger.
Show us.
Oh yeah, look at him go.
Woo Daniel, yeah it's a nice one.
Now the thing is you have to guide it a little
bit here with your hand, thumb with your thumb.
Yeah, so it doesn't wind up in the same spot.
Oh like that, the leaders in.
Come on Daniel, bring it bring it bring it.
Oh look at this guy.
What a beauty.
Thank you guys so much.
Cool cool cool.
Thank you.
That's it for us?
Hit the road.
You guys happy?
Perfect.
Good.
Get outta here.
That one pulled really hard.
I thought it was a yellow fin and it was
a long fin but that was so much fun.
My goodness.
Woo high five Daniel.
High five three, yes 3.
Three.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to head back.
The weather is changing here a little
bit and it is getting late so we're
going to head back and we're going to make
some sashimi and some sushi with these
tuna.
We've been driving for a while
but still got some ways to go.
We're going really fast now.
Just to see if we can get in front
of the container ship.
Right there.
There he goes.
Made it.
There we go.
All good.
Alright, land again
Good.
Now this is what you call fishing.
If you want to have an awesome time
catching tuna here in South Africa,
Hooked On Africa, I'll add all the details
for you in the video description down below.
And can you hold this one of us?
Yeah take photo.
OK there we go.
Water?
When they swim, these all come out.
When they they lie flat,
they lie in the groove there.
Yeah, so they actually are doing their thing.
That's awesome.
It's very cool, beautifully designed.
So they say they're going to take away
the fish and they're going to prepare
them for us but look... we've got a
visitor who wants to steal our fish.
If you want to go I'll show you where.
Alright.
Wow, this one.. that's the biggest one.
That's the biggest one.
Yeah 76 kilo.
That's a fat.
That's yours?
That is a big boy.
That's a lot of meat and it will keep you fed
for a few months and it's so rare to find this
good quality meat.
This is top grain.
They just brought us the
nice tuna steak right here.
So we're going to dig in.
They're going to bring us some tuna
sashimi and sushi as well in just a minute.
We're excited guys.
We're going to dig in here.
We're going to start eating.
Thank you, this looks so good.
So good.
So this tuna steak is sesame seed and
then here we just got some normal ones.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness, it can't get fresher than this,
right from the ocean.
Good Daniel.
And this is tuna fishing in South Africa.
Please remember to subscribe and we'll join
you in the next video.
Bye.